we don't know much about keanues but we
know every time you hear about Canada
Reeves it's of him doing the nicest
thing
like people will be like yeah my dog
Keanu Reeves [__] literally jumped in
front of a moving train to save my dog
or Henry's yeah dude I was talking to
Keanu Reeves and I mentioned he you know
I mentioned I need like some [__] a
blood transfusion and he straight up
drove me to the hospital and he gave me
some blood
I had an idea
I guess it comes from him not you know
what comes from for sure him not having
a Twitter or Instagram if Connor's had
an Instagram or Twitter it'd be over
you get if you have a Twitter and
Instagram you can get canceled you know
but if you don't you kind of can't
I mean you can but not really though
because Sean Connery doesn't have the
[__] and all the [__] he said people
were tweeting about that [__] but he
didn't have a Twitter I feel like if you
don't have a Twitter or an Instagram
people think they can't like write to
you so they're like oh he's not gonna
see it I think they do it when they're
like this mother because remember what
Sean Connery said about like you you
should slap women
and then he doubled down on it he was
having an interview and I was like so
you said you should stop women he's like
yes I think I think that you should and
he's like well I don't like that very
much he's like well sometimes they're
acting up worst worst [__] impression
ever but like he and and then and then
like people were like we gotta cancel
him and then it came out on Twitter a
little bit but then he doesn't have a
Twitter so people are like ah [__] it
uh well he's not gonna he's all he's old
I gotta get rid of all my [__] that's
the thing
um
I gotta get to the point where you look
at Albert that's the thing I always talk
about this it's like Al Pacino in some
you become undirectable in your own life
that's what it is
if you're not with a [__] hardcore if
you don't have somebody that grounds you
in a real way you go you're done you go
crazy like you need a wife or a [__]
real person that can just bring that's
what that's why that's why actors get so
bad that's why you're like what the [__]
happened to that actor used to be so
good now look what the [__] he's doing
because he was in he got too much of an
ego and then he started being in movies
and the directors couldn't hold him down
that's why every now and then Al Pacino
has a movie where he's just here like
what the [__] is he doing
he still kills it I mean he's still
brilliant and [__] as an actor can
actors even really be brilliant you know
but Al Pacino every now and then you're
like oh he's too Al Pacino because you
can't
direct that [__]
unless you're a [__] really good
director
's don't want to let don't want to tell
him they don't be like can you do it
this way because they know applejino is
going to be like why
and then you have to have an answer and
you're talking to the legend Al Pacino
De Niro these guys
uh walking is a great example really
really good but if you're [__] not
directing him he would just be like wow
wow
and then you'd be like okay
but that's probably because Kim K you
know is probably yeah that's the thing
if you have another out to lunch [__]
person on on your team
that's the thing I guess it's about
staying grounded
I don't like figuring this [__] out
before the show by the way I don't like
figuring it out I like talking it out
because we need to figure it out as a
cult
because this is a cult dude but staying
positive in the Limelight is amazing
staying positive and not losing your
[__] mind like Keanu Reeves has done
now granted he's only like 52.
but
there's this whole thing about doubling
down though now that like seems to work
because there's so many people out there
on the internet
like Trump and everybody just doubles
the [__] down look at Jesse samolette
any other time in history
[__] even 10 years ago he would have
been like yeah [__] up but he knows
there's enough people out there because
he sees them on the Internet that he's
like nah I I really got [__] jumped
even though he orchestrated the whole
goddamn thing
and it was Saddam
we know we know that he [__] made it
up there's still conspiracy theorists
out there there's enough of them there's
hundreds of thousands of [__]
that do this that think this
and he's just sitting there nah
he knows he's lying but he's like nah
didn't happen I got mugged and jumped
and because of that people like even
real people
like Anthony Anderson and [__] we'll be
like yeah dude
I believe him
huh I got question
huh
my thing is what about the so much
evidence
it has to be now though because it
doesn't last like everyone knows OJ
didn't do it I mean everyone knows OJ
did it sorry
so so it has to be now if some [__] goes
down now there's enough people to be on
your [__] team because there's too
many people in the world
it's just
there's too many people that's why I
think Thanos was right
you need to cut the [__] people in
half
you saw end game bro
the first one I was like
I'm on thanos's side look at all these
[__] look at how many [__] first
of all look how many annoying
superheroes there are
the half of those got to go
and then
some people don't have superpowers and
they're just we their mouths to feed
they gotta go dude